when you first started to make money
what did you do what was the first like
impulsive thing that you did i um
maybe the first movie because like early
on i died in a lot of movies so like i
in anaconda armageddon
uh the haunting so maybe the first movie
that i lived through shanghai noon
i was like okay i'm gonna treat myself
to something and i and i got and i know
it's a little bit of a hollywood cliche
but i got a porsche and uh i remember
going to buy the porsche and you know
going on to the lot and
the guy's kind of showing me the car and
he's like you're not going to get sand
kicked in your face with this car
and and i and i was kind of insulted
because i was like i'm not getting sand
kicked in my face now
you know
that's true for really any car you roll
the windows up
come
on but i would like to say i turned her
and walked off but no i went ahead and i
i got it and then when i got it then
like all the salesmen came out and
started cheering for me like you did it
owen like you got it it was like kind of
like you know when you walk into a sushi
restaurant everyone yells like arigato
it was like you know it was like kind of
embarrassing kind of and i kind of you
know drove off
yeah you felt a little self-conscious
yeah yeah i was never like a car guy but
there was after a bunch of years and i
had you know been doing well i thought
maybe i'll get that nice car and i went
to the same thing it was like
people drive these porches i want to
check it out so i went and i went in and
i think i was
the guy didn't know who i was and i was
just wearing like a t-shirt and a
leather jacket i went in and the guy was
i and he was saying those cars are
they're a lot of money and i went i know
i know i just want to try it out and he
clearly didn't think i had the money and
at one point i just said dude i have a
really long leg so the seats go back
just a little more than that and he went
just get out of the car
like you didn't have time to even let
the seat no no he was like just get out
of the car and i was like i walked away
this tired